yellow welcome to this video this is a
new one of three minute madness i
haven't done one of those for a long
time and i figured why not yeah it's fun
to do playing some reckless starting
three minute games and here we go I'm
really out to play wild openings let's
go at five that's probably complete
nonsense here but let's give it a wheel
in real a whirl I don't know go for it
yeah the early f pawn moves so yeah why
a three minute madness video because it
was a long long day in the office so to
say and I'd like to relax a little bit
anyway so what happens here let's go d 6
and push him away oh i'm giving away you
form hmm okay yeah shouldn't have done
that oops he whoa he's out for blood
that guy check okay wow is he
checkmating me immediately I was Queen
with Queen takes there maybe maybe you
just wants to take the route I don't
know check instead to mate we'll see i
know i have said aah chak you checkmate
it is a mate okay that was cool so f5 I
was a bit much why were you really
killed me there I don't look that it
looked like very game very tired stuff
okay so I'm out for revenge
let's play some really funky line who is
Pete Cherie by the way let me check this
Holden hand on this okay I don't know
that guy cam out for a form that looks a
bit crazy but that's the point of this
video so okay it's that good maybe night
before something but ok that looks
dangerous they're here on the on the
kingside check here schooling night to
have seven so probably just back I mean
g4 I can take it doesn't look so bad
yeah taking g5 hmm I think I'll do that
and get the pawn down strategically
dubious but if I win that pawn it's
pretty good I mean I didn't want to give
up the dark squared bishop but no choice
it's just too tempting check yeah this
is kind of the problem but not much that
I can do have to move the king if I get
to take g5 necks it cannot Castle long
that's pretty important and i'm playing
quickly here not thinking a long time so
what is he going to do night before or
what i am taking this okay it just just
it's not very not very dangerous there
in the first place
i mean if i take here even and go f6
okay in threatens on c2 hmm i didn't
really pay much attention there but well
hmm if i go f6 here Quincy to King eone
Quincy three check kingi to that's
that's not its ok right or not does he
have something that I don't see Bishop
g4 check he has maybe and then
cancelling long ha ok so Bishop g4 check
i have to take with the Queen I didn't
intend that at all but it might work at
least it's crazy now I have to play
Queens you form if you place the bishop
check but it might still be good i have
Queenie 6 threatening mates Queen a one
kidney to his out of checks check yeah I
have to take with this I cannot allow
him to castle and Queenie 6 is still an
ID threat remarkably King the eight I go
Quincy aid well he might have counter
text this is this can be a problem I
wonder can I do something better like f
seven or so where it's not so convincing
yes this night night take c to but i
have 91 then so Hank I can tell you this
stuff
I have to prove that looks completely
crazy but so here probably have to go up
check what what a wild game so I'm going
f7 here time warning check oh shoot eyes
got that check i blundered that one
unbelievable wow what a lucky guy here I
was completely winning so check check no
I'm threatening Quincy 8 it's not over
yet check check check before or
something check check check
check I don't see a win here check what
is he threatening their queen eff yeah
check I don't know I have to play moose
check check check check check check
check check black for fix hard time whoa
I mean yeah that was three minute
madness for you I have no idea what
happened in this game that was probably
the most incorrect game ever but I think
that's probably the purpose of the whole
business let's go for let's go for okay
wow wow okay yeah just in case you're
wondering I have in mind my well
deserved beer after teaching the whole
day and I'm having a bit of fun in this
session whoo Wow ok so I'm requesting a
new game don't get one yet what's up
there with three minute pool not much
going on I there is some there is some
there is some traffic then the pool but
I don't get a game somehow gain starting
a boob one yeah what can we do something
something crazy that's grand master boom
akhiyan ah come on come on something
been only strong Oh daft yeah he's right
a g6 that looks bad but ok he's a
grandmaster off yeah he was above 2600
even at some point well that takes lots
of time I mean it looks strategically
nice but it also takes ages what he's
doing there is that so great ship f5
that night has no squares mr.
Grandmaster what are you doing there
Quincy to set something that Quincy to
maybe check Quincy to i think was was
possible still some trickery and now i'm
a piece up it's probably not very amused
yeah how to do this probably just trade
this Bishop home
yeah I think I'll just keep that pawn
this is a pretty good person let's see
gather to clean them maybe maybe just
angle 45 and kill em that looks pretty
strong yeah give me g5 Queen 83 of the
threat now is playing without the
queendom that's not going to end well
check
good shake made check check white
resigns yeah he's probably not very
amused by this but well he just he just
put his night completely completely off
side I mean doc here I didn't quite get
why I mean he could have supplied Quincy
to I mean I don't want to analyze this
because it's just a broncos game but
here Quincy to was still possible he
didn't see that that saves the piece for
the moment as he has night yeah and
Hanks okay didn't see that game started
let's go against vex ma or work smile
it's wax ma probably Kings gambit action
yeah I don't know that lion had to admit
I know that this is right but check
don't ask me how it continues oh really
that works check I'm Bishop c5 or what
and I don't know maybe I should have
thought a little bit about it before I
played it but what is this by the way
it's equal material right so and see if
I can get rid of the Queen here
I never pretty open positions or
genetics ooh I didn't see that more cool
that's cool and out for wired right here
can I give him that rook hmm now it's
not going to work and I have to do that
unfortunately okay so let's give that
power at least I have some decent
development but the position is a
complete mess of course yeah Group B one
might happen with another tempo and I've
got the H file open probably something
like you can like a bishop before it's
pretty okay okay
check okay let's see night f7 yeah I saw
that but I wasn't sure that this is any
good let's see i can pick here check and
now queen d 7 is made and I'm
threatening night f7 with made chef
so just take this stuff there or it says
something better check yeah I guess I'm
taking stuff being a piece up it's not
bad okay I didn't see that one coming
okay jack it's so good for white I have
95 has a very big threat and I don't say
yes in a way to prevent it
black forfeits due to this connection i
understand it must be a bit frustrating
to have this kind of this kind of thing
sprung again on you again let's go for
the next for the next guy just in case
if you're wondering what kind of doping
I'm using here with that BM its pilsner
urquell one of my favorite brands that I
only discovered this year when I was
visiting the Czech Republic it's a one
of the original check beers it's very
very good okay have requested a new game
but poor doesn't seem to be so populated
at the moment yeah this video will be
about 30 minutes and seeing started
through something I'll go most
aggressive motor anyway okay the coop
right shake Sicilian don't get that too
often I don't think this that much i'll
just play in the most term active some
active moves and be quick about it can
you take on your phone or something like
that now should work here now okay let's
go back 595 there is no use your g for
business by gucci for now there might be
something bad happening to me mmm i
don't want to take on let's prepare that
it doesn't look so bad
looks like a reasonably normal Sicilian
position okay let's get out of that
diagonal you see castling long being
afraid but that's no good am after g5 I
wouldn't they have seven pawn can you do
something crazy like 94 94 94 Queen 82
I don't think that will work
okay okay interesting probably just
cover that be four was hanging I don't
get it and I can go here right and since
I'm technical I mean if it just has to
go back okay he just has to go back so
let's see that I can get the H file row
that's hard to believe fire just wow off
to e6
I don't get that move I have 95 now
right where's the big issue i have got
Queenie six next and Queenie seven made
I'm drinking a check p and I'm beating
someone from Slovakia who's that no no
name black resigns yo not too early made
only seven and the rookies hanging ok
gain started Nino DG ok so getting ready
for some and five based business here
unfortunately not all lines here are so
exciting there are a couple of lines
where white is basically taking material
and um yeah goes for end games ok this
is this is usually more interesting ok I
think I cannot castle right here because
of that Quincy for IDM have to do this
castle this Quincy find Bishop c6 the 95
tactics it's been very long time that I
looked at this line a couple of years I
think
that's let's go here and be quick about
it hmm interesting
hmm
what is your point mr. Nino DG
so he's playing for what before hmm c3 I
can also take them hmm let's do this
first
they can play that I mean you didn't
plan it but it just it does not lose
stuff it's quite unfair Jeff
check so is this position how bad is
that 25 who will play I guess I can go
and grab six it's not it's not bad so
yeah this is not good job fortunately
yeah see three year it was just about
working but it did work check you have
very little very little in terms of
compensation here for 15 points that I'm
down he's not playing well but it's
probably enough think Lee what is just
be it but okay it's too bad even a
couple of bad moves can probably not win
the position
check time morning check check i will
also just play uselessly on time hand at
time control check you play three
minutes you have to reckon with that
check check check yeah doesn't help it's
the completely lost a game so we managed
black resign in start a playing shades
who is that name nope but i know what
i'm going to do playing for the reverse
grand prix that can lead to funky at
taking games if white is not careful
looks like he is careful okay
so how do i play this him I don't know
the bishop I want it doesn't doesn't
feel very good okay like this ya hear
what is just better that's the problem
with those unsalted open he see if ever
Grand Master is sitting that he's not
he's playing well you just have a bad
position okay so how bad is that I'd if
I can get the bishop over to h5 this is
still kind of interesting maybe let's
keep that on the board and see it's also
possibly night if for just put that out
yeah so I don't mind if you take that
pawn I have some ideas on the light
squares and okay maybe here Queen edge
695 this kind of thing now g5 now it
doesn't help if i go to f7 he's got room
to seven so let's go here
possibly 95-93 is out for Queen be too I
guess but they have from Greece Evan
it's not such a big deal it can maybe go
age form later three king of one also
there but that's a bit bit of progress I
didn't didn't play that so badly I think
getting some chances out of a position
where I didn't feel like having a good
position okay no Knight f3 I can
actually do that check rookie 6 s creed
ii 1 so still a rookie 6 business is f4
move I can go F but then Bishop h3 is
pretty strong
f-for look is six however is working
I'm time morning yeah I know f-for
looking for Rookie 6f III it's not where
fg3 it's not working but it's close was
he going f3 now shoot yeah i just saw it
I and I think I had a good position here
ah what a shame what a shame but it's a
pretty strong player would like to get
something going down
check yeah he's just a piece of black
resigns I'm not really i don't want to
analyze in this time control but i'm
kind of curious check he is winning here
I don't have anything okay that I felt
like I might have something because the
light squares are so weak but i have no
continuation there I initially thought
here and she can still do that okay
let's go for one more i wanted to do 30
minutes but i know i've started that
game about Ron wow I've got no score
against him so let's spring this miss
more on him okay hmm okay that looks
like a very well I don't know i don't
know the theory here but that looks slow
got a very good development now you five
coming hmm that looks good for white to
be honest press f9 h 5 r should have
made night eh fiber thing yeah this is
just good for right of course but how
exactly it takes Ben Bishop t five wins
the exchange Bishop takes Bishop g5 if
he takes with the pawn that can take the
exchange first and I have a bishop c6
also let's do this first I guess check
Queen III is also pretty good move let's
do this threatening Quincy five check
yeah Oh bad he just moved the king ah
that wasn't what kind of pre move was
that he just moved the king I forgot
that he can move the king after this
joke of an opening oh my god ah I was so
completely winning here I just thought
he has to play rookie 70 Bishop e7 I
just forgot that he has key g8 I don't
believe this crazy ok it's not attacking
my queen as made on the aid
there is no mate he's got Bishop f8 haha
what the heck oh my god oh my god okay
I'm residing this game white reason I
had good fun in this session anyway even
though this is this was it was pretty
terrible I me I can just take this rook
and win yeah and it was I mean I was
just playing far too fancy I absolutely
thought that I'm checkmating India I
thought yeah pre-move I thought this is
why I pre-move troop d 8 because I
thought he only has Bishop e7 or rookie
seven and then as root d8 made I mean
queen t6 there's no route to a pre move
the things i'm just still winning yet if
I just do this also then end game at
that time that the tech is just
devastating well I assume I simply
didn't didn't see that yes dg8 oh my god
okay i hope you enjoyed this session I
definitely did thanks for watching